If you watched the Trump impeachment inquiry
hearings with us the last couple of weeks,
you probably noticed this
Republican Congressman Devin Nunez, who is
doing a hell of a lot of talking, certainly
more than I wanted to hear from him.
Uh, the reason he was doing that is he's the
ranking member of the house intelligence committee.
So he got to issue opening and closing statements
right alongside the chairman of the committee.
Um, Adam Schiff.
And every time Devin Nunez would go on and
on about how the ratings were down for the
hearings, how the hearings were a waste of
time, how there's simply nothing to see here.
It's all pointless.
And Trump didn't do any bribery, corruption,
extortion, quid pro quo.
And he certainly wasn't looking to force Ukraine
to smear Biden or looking for dirt on Biden.
And it now turns out this has been a stunning
weekend of news that Devin Nunez himself was
allegedly involved in trying to find smears
of Joe Biden himself.
The calls are coming from inside the house,
so to speak.
Devin Nunez is part of the impeachment hearings
as a questioner of witnesses.
He is now implicated in what the impeachment
hearings are meant to investigate.
It's yet another person who, because of their
personal conflicts and in this case alleged
corruption should have nothing to do with
the proceedings whatsoever.
This is like attorney general Jeff sessions
recusing himself from anything Russia related.
This is like attorney general William Barr,
who right now should be recusing himself from
anything Ukraine related that may come before
the justice department because of his involvement,
uh, and being implicated in it.
Devin Nunez can't be investigating this.
He's part of what we are trying to investigate.
He should be a witness answering questions,
not a member of the committee asking them.
So I'll set this up for you.
Rudy Giuliani, Donald Trump's a lawyer.
I struggle with what to even call him now.
He is a lawyer who works with or for Donald
Trump or did at least at one point.
Uh, Rudy has these two associates who were
recently arrested, uh, love Parness and Igor
Fruman, the lawyer representing one of them
loved Parness, said that Parness is ready
to testify under oath that Devin Nunez himself
met with a former Ukrainian prosecutor Shoken
in 2018 to talk about investigating Joe Biden
and his son, Hunter Biden.
Devin Nunez reportedly went to Vienna, Austria
to meet with Ukrainian prosecutor general
Victor Shoken, who is himself at the center
of a lot of what is going on here.
Shoken ended up being fired after a whole
bunch of leaders said, this guy isn't doing
his job.
And of course Trump's has Shoken was fired
in order to protect Hunter Biden.
Now this might not be true, the allegation
being made by Lev Parness here.
Maybe love Parness is making it up, but number
one, it would be extremely risky for Lev Parness
to be making this up without being able to
have some evidence suggesting that it's true.
And we will get to the topic of evidence next
because it turns out, Oh Lordy, there are
tapes, but I don't want to get ahead of myself.
The allegations about Nunez do line up with
known facts about noon as having meetings
in Europe around this time, which by the way,
you the taxpayer paid for, and I'll get to
that a little bit later.
If this is true, the hearings themselves have
been infiltrated by people who should be targets
of the investigation.
Devin Nunez shouldn't be asking questions.
He should be answering them.
The ranking members should be recognized as
a witness, not as someone who gets to participate
in the hearings.
Should any of us be surprised about this?
Newness is the guy who, while he was chairman
of the house intelligence committee back before
Democrats took control of the house, he was
supposed to be investigating Trump and he
was actually running to the white house to
let Trump know what they were doing.
So it shouldn't be surprising.
This is one of the dirtiest Republicans in
this entire Trump era, and it's actually even
worse.
Not only did Devin Nunez apparently do this,
he did it on taxpayer money.
He did it with your money.
A new ethics complaint, claims that Devin
Nunez spent $57,000 in taxpayer money to go
to Europe himself and with staff to try to
dig up dirt on Joe Biden and to convince European
officials to get involved in the smears of
Joe Biden.
Your money was spent on this.
They need to get this guy off of the committee
and instead under oath himself to answer questions,
he should recuse himself immediately from
any future hearings, even if only 5% of what's
being alleged is true.
And at this point, even talking about resignation
is reasonable here.
This is one of the dirtiest, dirtiest guys.
This is their hero from the hearings along
with Jim Jordan.
And he is actually involved.
He's complicit in what is being investigated.
But this is not the only news from this weekend
related to Rudy Giuliani's associate left
Parness or what we learned from him.
There is more
and
it is tapes.
Let's talk about that next.